they haven't actually spoken yet we are
expecting the chief constable John
Campbell the Chief Constable of Thames
Valley Police to say a few words as well
as Reverend heft Helen Arnold just ahead
of that minute's silence when Thames
Valley Police Force will fall silent as
a tribute to their fallen colleague PC
Andrew Harper that will be an exactly 11
o'clock and not just here in Redding
where Thames Valley Police operate but
forces across the country will also be
marking this very special moment to pay
tribute to this fallen police officer
who was killed while responding to call
calls of an attempted burglary last
Thursday evening members of PC Andrew
hoppers family are also in attendance at
Thames Valley Police Headquarters and
officers like these two gentlemen behind
me here they will also be marking that
one minute's silence at 11 o'clock
already this morning we've had people
laying flowers and other tributes at
this spot here where the incident took
place last week we have a number of
police officers working just along here
on that Lane and they're still gathering
evidence to present in that prosecution
when that trial does come up but we are
expecting
Thames Valley Police Chief Constable
I'm saying a few words any moment now
he'll be saying just how heroic PC
Andrew Harper's actions were how much
he'll be missed by colleagues have been
leaving tribute ear I read one just a
short time ago from an officer who said
she'd never met PC Andrew Harper but had
been inspired by his bravery in the fact
is that he will leave a very big hole
his training center here at so instead
we are joined by the family of Andrew PC
Andrew Harper for this remembrance we
are also joined by colleagues from the
fire and ambulance service whose staff
were involved and supported us in
responding to Andrews death
I'm joined also by Helen who's our
fourth chaplain in a moment we will have
a minute silence and will be signifying
the stars for that minute silence with
the police whistle a police whistle has
been long associated with sacrifice and
was used as the method of ordering young
men over the top during the First World
War
it is also traditionally associated with
police officers in the past calling for
help from their colleagues this is not a
memorial service there will be a time
for words and memories in the days and
weeks and years to come this is a time
for gathering a time to pause and a time
to reflect we gather here one week from
the tragic death of PC Andrew Harper our
dearly loved and respected colleague
friend and proud police officer son
brother and husband we're here to offer
our respects and to acknowledge his
passing we are now in a different place
and things feel very different
we remember Andrew for how life was
richer for knowing him we give thanks
for all that he gave his enthusiasm is
care for others his commitment to
policing this police family to which he
belonged we'll never forget him and we
pray especially for his family and close
friends for whom Andrews death has left
such emptiness me we with them know a
healing touch peace in our confusion and
light in our dark times through the love
we share with one another so in this
moment let us still busy hearts and
minds as we remember a colleague and
friend Andrew in silence now
moment as we come face-to-face with
death let us draw closer and love
traveled together in these difficult
hours and days and open our hearts to
comfort one another may love and peace
rest with you and those whom you love
and with those who love you today and
always
Thank You Helen there but now his
conclusion to this short remembrance
ceremony please take the time if you can
to to look at the wonderful tributes and
flowers to Andrey this is just a small
part of the many tributes that have been
laid at the scene of Andrews death and
also have been received by the force
from both police colleagues foreign
ambulance military and members of the
public as well and a a true reflection
of how Andrews passing has been felt by
us locally but also by the rest of the
country thank you for coming and wish
you well for the rest of the day
PC Harper's death has really touched so
many people as his Chief Constable was
just saying they're not here only here
in Redding but around the country in
fact Thames Valley Police had so many
messages of condolence that they had to
open a dedicated email address where
members of the public could write in
expressing their grief their sorrow
their support for the portal for PC
Harper's family also a just giving pages
managed to raise over two hundred and
sixty thousand pounds in a space of just
a few days there are people around here
this morning there's a lady probably as
you can see over my shoulder there who's
been waiting by the side of the road
with flowers and she's been waiting
there she observed her minute's silence
and to be walking up here
lay those flowers with the other
tributes which have been left here and
that just goes to show
exactly how this death has been received
not just in this community but police
forces across the country saying they
will also be marking today as a day of
not just remembrance but a tribute to
all officers who go out every day and
face and expose themselves to danger
this will try and speak to this lady as
she comes up but another example of just
how much PC Harper's death has touched
members of the local community here
remember he was report he was attending
to what seemed at the time a report of
an attempted burglary and a dress just
down the road here we'll let this lady
pay her tributes to PC Harper
good morning mom likes to jump from Sky
News
you've come here to pay your tributes to
PC Andrew Harper why did you feel it was
necessary for you to come and do this
here this morning because as a policeman
working in the community this shouldn't
have happened
you know it's sad it's we decide
my present total with the family and I
wish to be strong keep being strong
don't let this stop what they do best
thank you very much what's your name
Danielle Danielle any other thank you
very much gentlemen Sky News this
morning Daniel are just one of the many
people who have been coming here this
morning putting down their flowers and
and just playing their own personal
tributes to PC Andrew harp and I'm sure
that will continue throughout the day
here in reading but also right
throughout the country too